[Aplausos]
es eric adams
el nuevo alcalde demócrata de nueva york
será el segundo afroamericano en
gobernar la ciudad en su discurso de
celebración reafirmó la personalidad
mostrada en campaña
hermanos y hermanas y toda la gente de
nuestra ciudad ya hablaron y esta noche
nueva york' escogió a uno de ustedes
yo soy ustedes yo soy ustedes después de
años de rezar y desear y luchar entramos
al alcalde del guaje le sucedió
en la jornada de votación del martes
eric adams acudió a votar con un retrato
de su madre fallecida el pasado año ha
sido uno de los ganchos de campaña para
llegar al ciudadano de a pie
adam suele hablar de su infancia pobre
se define obrero es vegano y considera
haber sido traicionado por las
instituciones cuando su madre no podía
comprar comida o cuando siendo
adolescente era golpeado por policías
precisamente adams fue ex capitán de
policía y hasta su lanzamiento de la
carrera de alcalde presidente del
distrito de brooklyn
así se expresaba en 2020 sobre el que ha
sido otro de los grandes pilares de su
campaña la seguridad
nos acostumbramos a creer que la
violencia es normal en nuestra comunidad
pero no lo es estas madres perdieron a
sus niños no son solo fotos
adams destaca por haber sabido llegar a
los distintos grupos sociales de la
ciudad consiguiendo 9 millones de
dólares de recaudación de campaña lo
cual le costó el cuestionamiento por
parte del ala más a la izquierda del
partido demócrata su periodo de gobierno
comenzará en enero cuando sustituirá al
actual alcalde bill de blasio